hello and welcome to the cheeky sign she
were in this video I'm going to talk all
about cellular senescence in more detail
than I have done in previous videos and
why our lab is researching it
so cellular senescence is often
described by two key characteristics one
of which is a cell cycle arrest when the
cell stops proliferating and the second
is the secretion of faxes which they
refer to as the senescence associated
secretory phenotype otherwise known as
ASP but these are just two
characteristics of senescence cells and
more recently there have been four key
hallmarks that have been used to
describe cellular senescence in addition
to cell cycle arrest and the secretory
phenotype senescence cells are also
characterized by macro molecular damage
and a deregulated metabolic profile but
it's important to remember that these
four different hallmarks are not
independent they are also interdependent
and depend on each other and so it's
somewhat better to think of cellular
senescence as a collective phenotype and
so this collective phenotype can help
with the identification of senescence
cells and this is of interest because it
can help with the understanding of
senescence and its involvement with age
and age associated diseases such as
cancer so you might now be wondering
what actually causes a cell to become
senescence and why do we see these four
different characteristics and not other
characteristics well it turns out there
are lots of different ways that you can
induce a cell to become senescence this
includes telomere attrition genotoxic
drugs that are used to treat cancer
irradiation on kinetics dress after
replicating so many times and also
oxidative stress say replicative
senescence is that forma senescence that
is most often talked about and that is
caused by telomere attrition which is
when their telomeres these repetitive
sequences at the ends of chromosomes
they shorten over time as a cell divides
and so these sequences are just repeats
of ttaggg DNA nucleotides and they're
bound by this complex of proteins
referred to as the sheltering complex
and so this protects the ends of the DNA
from being recognized as double-stranded
break
which kids stimulates the DNA damage
response the problem is as these
telomeres shorten that protection gets
lost and DNA damage can be activated
within a cell that can cause cellular
senescence so why doesn't a cell prevent
this telomere attrition from occurring
well besides in a few cells where they
do have the capability to enhance length
of telomeres it is thought that by
limiting the number of times that a cell
can divide this can help to prevent the
development of tumors and this is
because tumors can develop from
uncontrolled proliferation say by
limiting the number of times a cell can
divide it instead causes result and to
replicative senescence and to pathways
impulsiveness involved the protein p53
and retinoblastoma
and what these pathways do is they can
activate proteins their inner cyclin
dependent kinase inhibitors that help to
prevent the cell cycle and they caused
cell cycle arrest and so one of these
proteins is p16
however mutations and the genes encoding
these proteins could enable a cell to
escape senescence and continue to
replicate which could lead to tumor
development so because of its function
in preventing the cell cycle p16
is commonly used as a marker of
senescence cells and interestingly in
studies whereby they've cleared cells
expressing p16
so removing these senescence cells
they've delayed age associated disorders
in mice so the cell cycle arrest is a
way of preventing damaged cells from
replicating further and potentially
causing the tumor development but what
is the role of the senescence associated
secretory phenotype so senescent cells
irrespective of the inducer of
senescence have been shown to secrete a
variety of different factors that
include pro-inflammatory factors
signaling molecules known as cytokines
growth modulators that can induce the
formation of blood vessels and also
factors that can modulate the
surrounding extracellular matrix of the
cell but the question is why so a
function for each of the individual
factors is far from complete but
currently the understanding
is that the SAS can mediate the variety
of pathological and physiological
effects that are associated with
senescent cells so some of these effects
includes the ability of this ask to
reinforce and cause the spread of
senescence to other neighboring cells it
is also thought that this ask can
activate the immune response to help
eliminate these senescence cells and to
remove them Weston essence and fast have
also been shown to play a key role in
wound healing and development
however if senescence cells are not
removed because they express this
inflammatory task it can result in
chronic inflammation which can have
deleterious Pro aging effects and
services also sometimes refer to you as
inflammation for these reasons
there's a lot of interest in
understanding this task and in
particular it is known that the strength
of the Sask and also the composition of
these different factors can vary
depending on the context so the cell
type in which the essence of cars and
also the contacts including how
senescence is induced in the first place
so another hallmark of senescence cells
is macro molecular damage and in
particular this can include damage not
only to DNA but also to proteins and
lipids and other molecules found within
a cell particularly prone to damage are
the attina Murs that we've already
spoken about but this time instead of
the reduction and then for telomeres
this is damaged independent of telomere
length and these characteristics are
known as telomere associated face ie
where you have the co-localization of
telomeres with gamma h2ax which is a
sign of DNA damage and dysfunction one
of the ways that this damage can occur
is through the accumulation of reactive
oxygen species within a cell they're not
only caused damage to t limits but can
also cause proteomic damage in addition
enhance proliferation from oncogenic
induced senescence
can cause damage to DNA due to collapse
of replication forks during DNA
replication processes that can therefore
remove these damaged proteins is
therefore advantageous to a senescent
cell and so up regulated incessant cells
is a process known as otology which
to eliminate damaged and unfolded
proteins so senescent cells are often
referred to as zombie cells however
senescent cells are actually highly
energetic and are constantly producing
these factors that we've already spoken
about in this ASP and so it requires
energy that is generated in the form of
ATP for a mitochondrial however in
addition to the production of ATP
mitochondria also produce these reactive
oxygen species that we've already spoken
about and so this can increase the
amount of protein damage and therefore
requires the cells it depends more on
energetic processes such as otology that
just feels this increase further in
reactive oxygen species interestingly
the removal of mitochondria a process
known as might of G has been shown to be
able to suppress the secretory phenotype
so in addition to these four key
hallmarks of senescence cells there are
also changes that are seen at the
chromatin level and so this is the DNA
and its associated proteins and refers
to the way in which DNA is organized
within the cell and how open or
compacted it is and it's gonna have
implications for the stability of the
genome and also for individual gene
expression interestingly in some
senescence cells in particular oncogenic
induced senescence are the observation
of these heterochromatic face I referred
to as senescence associated
heterochromatic through sight otherwise
known as South and these can be
visualized as Dappy dense regions in the
nucleus and so Dappy is what's used
sustained DNA one way in which to study
these changes in genome organization
include hi-c and this process requires
both experimental and computational
methods to execute so recently in the
lab we have described senescence as a
physiological life cycle whereby normal
cells can get exposed to stress and that
stress can lead to the induction of
senescence and the development of this
ASP which can therefore enable the
recruitment of immune cells to clear D
senescence cells away and to resolve any
stress that has occurred and to get back
to normal so this helps to prevent
broods
of damaged cells that may be at risk of
malignant transformation however we also
think that senescence has a dual role in
cancer and also has negative
consequences that can come from in
particular the secretory phenotype that
have pathological consequences including
cancer formation chronic inflammation
and age associated disorders so studying
senescence is of great importance and
there are many different questions that
we are trying to address within the lab
these includes how gene expression is
regulated during senescence compared
with other stress responses this can
help with the identification of
senescence cells and the development of
senna lytx which are drugs that can
remove and eliminate Messam cells we are
also interested in how cell
communication modulates mesons
associated phenotypes and in particular
this focuses on the secretory phenotype
whereby these signaling molecules
results in the communication between
senescence cells and normal cells and
immune cells and how this implicates
senescent cell clearance and say we're
also interested in how senescence
modulates tumor initiation and the role
that senescence cells play in the
initiation and early stages of tumor
development and another key question is
how aging itself contributes to tumor
Genesis and the potential triggers of
senescence but this is just some of many
questions that we're addressing within
the lab so hopefully this video has
given you a better understanding of what
cellular senescence is and why we're
studying it if you're interested in
finding out more about our lab check out
our website or follow us on Twitter
where you'll see updates on what the lab
is doing and publications within our lab
but also similar labs so as always if
you've learnt something and thanks for
listening